i can't stand up i have a food woody
i love not being on network television
right now
[Music]
what's up everyone i'm andrew zimmern
and these are my favorite snacks from
all around the world as you might expect
[Music]
chyna in the house two of my favorite
all-time snacks
we have sichuan peanuts we have li hing
muy
which are salted preserved plums let's
break into those plums
first i was first exposed to this
traveling to china and then i
found that they were in every hawaiian
snack shop
that i would go into on any island and
it comes like this these are
pitted already and we will choose them
but there is literally nothing better
than leahey mui flavor
it's the fermented plum taste that you
can count on flip side
of the snack world are these peanuts
anywhere that you go in sichuan province
when you go into a bar or restaurant you
get a bowl of peanuts they're
cooked with chilies and the szechuan
peppercorns so these are made so well
that when i get to the bottom of the bag
i put the last couple nuts into a spice
grinder
and you get a peanut szechuan peppercorn
chili crumble that i put on
everything this here is one of my top
three desert island snacks of all time
and
potentially if you really pushed me and
said you can only have one snack
this might be it
matcha kitkat japanese i mean they're
the only folks who are brilliant enough
to make kitkats in every single flavor
known to man i mean these were cultish
when they came out
if you remember a couple years ago you'd
pay a hundred dollars a bag on the
internet because everyone was looking
for you know oh my god
green tea kitkat and they came out with
mango and it was like oh my god mango
kitkat but if you went to japan
there were like 100 flavors maybe the
global snack
master culture is japanese
oh i can't stand up
i have a food woody i love not being on
network television right now
it's time for mexican candy their candy
culture is crazy and i love candy
that is sour salty sweet bitter and
spicy
this one is like a mango taffy that
comes on a stick
that has all of those delicious spicy
salty sweet sour bitter flavors
and this is a lollipop so here's the
best part right
and you roll it around in all of that
powder
comes out it's seasoned again so that
fruity caramel candy you can just
keep re-seasoning with this insanely
salty and spicy mixture in there so you
just keep hitting it like a lab rat
wow here are two of the most popular
snacks in korea
these are just seasoned dried
squid legs i'm a big fan of the legs
especially ones that still have the
suction cups
on them this is a sign of quality
mildly seasoned just a tiny little bit
of sweetness there
tiny little bit of rice wine something
salty and soyish
now this is the korean version of a very
popular snack
a peanut and robed in peanut butter
with a rice cracker casing on it so it's
kind of like a
savory peanut m m but what's
mixed in with that peanut butter is
dried cuttlefish
it's crunchy and then it's creamy and
it's crunchy with the nut again
and then it's got the contrast of the
sweet and the salty
sometimes people ask me how did you
discover all this stuff
and the answer is really simple i did
something other people don't like to do
i asked for help i know
it's a very un-american concept but it's
okay
i have this theory i like myself better
in foreign countries than i do in
america the andrew who's traveling
abroad
is a more curious person he's polite
he takes more risks i learn more
going into a supermarket in a foreign
country about their culture than i do go
into a museum
[Music]
my body is a machine my body's a temple
i spend a lot of time
working out you don't get to look like
this by lazing around and eating on your
couch
all the time this is an athlete's build
so i don't want to like
sit down and eat two or three buttered
and jammed croissants for a snack
when i have a flight from one city to
another so i like to carry
dried meat snacks and one of my
favorite dried meat snacks in all the
world
is southern african biltong
now this is seasoned beef typically with
black pepper and coriander seed
and sometimes a little bit of chili for
heat almost to the form
of charcuterie i mean this is like
stained glass
and they still leave some of the fat on
it's perfect
it's a higher quality of beef jerky this
stuff is
just insane and it's beefy it's real
beef
truly seasoned and dried the right way
and rosy and pink
and it's just it's a cut above get it
[Applause]
[Music]
so that's it i'm andrew zimmern you've
been watching snack tune in to discovery
plus the magnolia app catch new episodes
of family dinner that's me i'm in it
check that out and to all the folks at
snack thank you very much for indulging
me and having me on talking about one of
my
favorite subject snacks